foreign
who you have interviewed yes on Dark
Horse He is a journalist maybe you want
to describe yeah he is a freelance
journalist who has done an immensely
good job of placing himself in the place
where history is unfolding multiple
times now he was actually on the ground
uh at January 6th among other things
right at the Capitol anyway he he's
interesting for a number of reasons one
he is exceedingly good at being
even-handed right his politics he wears
on his sleeve but they do not impact the
way he reports this when somebody's
being a fool it doesn't matter which
side they're on he he points to it and
describes it very well and he happens to
be far left right he's he described he's
far enough left he describes himself as
an anarchist when pressed on it he's not
simply an anarchist he has a a rather
nuanced understanding of anarchism and
in what way it might be positive I of
course disagree with him on this but
nonetheless
uh he comes from the far left
um but he has
um he has critiqued left and right with
equal uh uh with equal attention to
detail in recent times and uh so he he
was on the ground in Portland during our
uh
meltdown
what's the person that call a backup
a nightly recurring Riot that goes on
for over 100. yeah
um I don't know what you call it but in
any case he was he was there for that so
anyway he has continued to do this where
he figures out where things are
happening and he shows up and he
documents them and he's collaborated
with people whose bent is more of a
photographic in video nature in many
cases anyway quite like the guy really
like what he's been doing you want to
talk a little bit about his uh his most
recent thing from La magazine yeah so uh
he has written this piece and you can
just show my screen I'll just read a bit
from it
um called trans yeah there it is uh
exclusive transgender fugitive who
spurred we Spa riots Bears all Theron
merricker I don't know if I'm
pronouncing his name correctly the just
arrested Angelina who launched a
firestorm from a women's locker room
spoke with LA magazine while on the lamb
uh and so uh merricker again I may be
mispronouncing his name is now in
custody but he was not for something
like 15 months I think and while he was
not in custody and he was being looked
for uh Jeremy Lee Quinn sat down with
him and did this this interview uh which
is quite quite interesting so let's just
read so for those uh many people may
remember that in the early summer or
June of 2021 there's a spa in LA's Korea
town called the Wii Spa
it's not a women's Spa but it has like a
woman's floor and a men's floor and they
went on to their site I don't remember
there's like I've never been
um but there there are it's it's got sex
segregated spaces and there's also
non-sex segregated spaces but um the
locker room
um the locker rooms are sex segregated
and this dude walked into women's locker
room
naked and into the hot tubs I guess in
the women's segregated spaces
um you know penis out and got called to
account for it I think I think
um the first woman who said what are you
doing here actually she got escorted off
the premises first uh but then
ultimately
um he had uh indecent exposure charges
thrown at him and then he was a fugitive
from Justice for like 15 months so um as
Jeremy Lee Quinn writes it Darren
merricker the transgender Angelino at
the center of an indecent exposure row
that began in the summer of 2021 at a
Koreatown spa and then exploded into a
national Scandal has been arrested in La
after 15 months on the lamb
it was June 23 2021 at we spawn Wilshire
and South Rampart when 52 year old
merricker caused a near Riot by exposing
his or was it her penis to a locker room
full of women in September 2021 the LA
County D.A filed five felony accounts of
indecent exposure against mariger and
since the Arcadia native has been the
red hot center of a huge blow up over
trans rights
Okay so
a few and then he does this this
interview
Quinn does this interview with merricker
and it's quite
quite remarkable
he America goes to the protests that are
erupting about him okay but he goes as
himself which is to say he's a dude he
looks like a dude just looks like a dude
and he goes and sits in his car
and uh
and he says I was first here we have I
was first contacted by a black female
who then went and summed a large group
to confront me it appeared to be a
mixture of antifa types as well as this
black and pink grip
he
continues that they thought that he was
a proud boy
because he just looks like this big dude
sitting sending in a an Escalade and
they say no you're a proud boy People
Like Us don't drive Escalades that's a
new rule apparently it's a sign of birth
you will or you will not have asked
access to Escalades yeah so now we know
that the people who were protests and on
behalf of this dude's right to expose
himself in women's locker rooms and in
women's Spas we're hassling him for
looking like a proud boy and Escalade
and didn't believe that he was the trans
woman at the center of this well wait
wait I want to add something you may be
going there but
in the interview it's quite clear he is
under No Illusion whatsoever about
whether or not he looks like a man in
fact at one point in the interview he
says how would anybody know if I didn't
tell him right but this is not
a simple case of somebody gaming the
system
because well go ahead so let's just read
this section that I think you're
referring to here let's back up let's
back up a second Quinn says should we be
using male or female pronouns with you
how do you identify
he says I'm very neutral like non-binary
although I don't like that word I'm
legally female but I have facial hair I
have a penis I have no breasts I don't
have a feminine voice I don't wear
makeup or dress up like a female
so imagine you're a grocery store clerk
and you're bagging my groceries and you
say Excuse me sir I mean am I supposed
to be offended that'd be ridiculous how
would this person know but technically
for legal terms I am she her I put
female on my driver's license but I've
had to struggle my whole life fitting
into traditional Society
Quinn says and you sleep with women
you're a female who has heterosexual sex
with females
merger whatever his name is says I have
heterosexual sex because my penis fits
in a vagina I don't tell women I'm with
that I'm transgender because that's not
my sex so I'm not faking anything gender
is internal sex is external
he got his sex change changed He got His
official designation changed because
California law law now allows you to do
that just by saying I've decided I'm a
different sex
he is being somewhat precise in his
language here but the fact is that he is
gaming the system
he he is he he is just making a claim
that he feels like a woman and he is
actually in no way in no way
in no way doing anything
um that appears to have him be be
woman-like even so so two more here
well okay it's sort of relevant to that
okay when I read that
um it created some sympathy for him in
my mind
and he loses that sympathy later on for
reasons we will get to but my sense is
okay on the one hand this is a person
who is certainly clearer about where
they are and what their expectations are
with respect to the world than most
folks if you were purely gaming the
system the idea that he has the right to
be called she by some clerk who has no
way of knowing might well be on the the
list of expectations here he's saying
look how would a clerk know there's no
outward sign this is about an inward
feeling but my point my point is this
this person is confused
most people are confused about many many
things a number of people who do not
have profound confusions running around
in their mind uh is very small at the
moment
I can't begrudge him
taking the world at its word that if you
feel differently inside saying okay I am
now female and going to the lengths of
changing your legal status
he
I don't see that as gaming the system I
see this as somebody who has taken what
he's told are the new rules of the
system and saying this makes sense for
me now this this strikes me as the most
obvious case of someone who has seen
what he can do he literally has
heterosexual sex with women he literally
he's he's a dude who likes to have sex
with women and he does and he doesn't
tell them that he goes and pretends to
be a woman because he got his legal
status changed in order to get himself
into spas and hang out with a bunch of
naked women like so that's that's what
he has gotten like that that is he gets
to walk around with and you know I don't
I as you know did not like to
to play this card as it were but he gets
to walk around with the privilege the
big brawny men walk around with he gets
to walk around at night with a lot less
fear that oh my God I gotta make sure I
don't turn down that corner or down
where there's a street light out or this
side or the other because he's walking
around like a dude because he is a dude
right and then he and then because he he
had one legal thing changed as soon as
the law changed to California and now he
gets to go and swing his dick around in
a women's spot no but you're right that
that's Apollo the question is whether
what is appalling is that that is the
new set of rules or whether what is
appalling is his availing himself of
that rule I've had to struggle my whole
life fitting into traditional Society he
says the right keywords there is nothing
here so he says
um was that something that was discussed
with your therapist Quinn asks how did
you come the decision to make the
appointment to go in to get the driver's
license changed this is the only thing
that's different for him right yep
he says our discussion basically started
around April 2017. between April 2017
and 2019 I had figured that evaluating
how I fit and how I had problems in
prison you come to the conclusion that
makes more sense where you're going to
fit better in life he's doing this
because he doesn't want to be in a Men's
prison the next time he's arrested for
being a criminal right perfectly
rational perfectly rational and having
not like why would you why would you
have compassion for a male criminal who
knows he's going to end up in prison
again for thinking ahead and putting all
the women prisoners at risk instead
because I believe in good governance and
I believe that it is Our obligation to
create a set of rules that is sensible
to have discretion built into the system
for edge cases don't just give me a look
like what is your problem yeah what is
your problem no the dog and I know
um
um
there are two questions here okay one
are you going to fault people for
utilizing the rules as they are laid out
to my way of thinking you have insane
people who somehow gained power to
change the rules that the rest of us
live by right those people are
despicable right they are involved in a
power game somebody who looks at the
rules and does what
they think matches best he doesn't think
it's what matches best it means he
doesn't have to go to a Men's prison
perfectly right he's gonna and yes
rational but having nothing to do with
whether or not he actually feels like a
woman he doesn't
well I don't know but you are a
convicted sex offender aren't you Glenn
asks him weren't you once caught without
pants and masturbating while peering
into the window of an 85 year old
Arcadia woman
so what happened was this elder the man
got to use the bathroom in the middle of
the night and his bathroom overlooks
another yard and he saw me masturbating
but even if it was masturbation I don't
have a problem with that because that's
not illegal it's only illegal if you're
masturbating in someone's face like
George Michael
a that's not an answer B he's despicable
yeah this is one of two places where he
lost my sympathy but I don't understand
how he had your sympathy at all he's
clearly clearly doing everything he can
to put himself in women's spaces where
he can be
criminal I like there's lots of words I
could say there but he he is he's going
to end up in a women's prison if he ends
up in prison again and there he will be
putting all of the women at risk I guess
he has no place in the women's prison he
has no place in Walmart we both agree he
has no place in women's prison he has no
place in a women's Spa
totally agree however the people who are
really at fault here are the people who
change the rules so that a guy like this
has discretion but he also has no he's
no confusion he has no remorse he says
look I know I'm a dude I have sex with
with women because
he walks us through it right and then he
just says oh yeah you know because I
haven't fit in in life like everyone
doesn't fit in sometimes dude look you
may be right that he's gaming the system
and I don't necessarily detect it
nonetheless
you've got two possible worlds
you have a world
in which
we make
rules that make sense and everybody is
held to them or you have a world in
which dangerous people are allowed to
create a hellscape in which you have
choices you shouldn't have and they
decide who will be flagged for making
those choices and who will not right you
have monsters deciding on the rules of
sex and gender
silencing biologists and doctors and
anybody else who would dare speak up and
point out how insane this is and then on
the street they're saying here's how we
know you're full of [ __ ] you drive and
Escalade okay so now they approached him
because he looks like in their words a
proud boy right
okay but
he couldn't possibly no no
we have the same I'm going to forget the
name of the institution that was shot up
in the recent uh shooting that was
touted as a conservative shooting up a
trans space and then the guy turned out
to identify the Colorado Springs the the
queer bar outside of Colorado right take
a look at that here you've got a
situation in which a queer bar is shot
up you have everybody saying well this
is obviously anti-queer and then it
turns out that the person who did the
shooting identifies as queer and the
point is well we know he's not right you
are free to tell us whether you do or
don't identify but if you turn out to be
one of the ones we don't like then we
are in a position to say you're making
it up so I don't like a world in which
discretion has anything to do with this
right but I mean I guess
it's all discretion no it's not all
discretion the fact is
if
the monsters are going to make a rule
that says hey if you tell us you're
female you're female if you say you're
trans you're trans right if they make
that rule they have to live with the
downside of that argument okay but so I
don't know where this guy falls I don't
know he could be pure monster and he
could be have no gender confusion no
strange feeling inside of him be saying
that because it's the right thing to say
that's perfectly possible and it's
consistent with a couple of things in
this article or he could be somebody who
is looking at the rules as they are laid
out and saying actually in light of the
rules this is what I am
I don't I don't buy it for a second not
with this guy
um what one more segment here
to read
he
he is saying
that someone a guy a a trans woman I
guess uh who goes by Bambi Salcido I may
be mispronouncing that
um
is I guess I'll just read this and you
can show my screen if you like Zach
um just while I'm reading it you mean
Bambi Salcido Quinn writes president and
CEO of the trans Latin at Coalition the
largest translate organization in LA
she said in a story about you you'd
think after getting arrested a bunch of
times she just changed clothes in a
stall
so Bambi does refer to this guy as a she
yes and the big guy his name I keep
forgetting says right so in the article
she says she goes to we spot three times
a year and she gets naked in there she
never has a problem so I spoke to Bambi
Salcido on the phone before the story
came out she admitted to me that she has
boobs and she takes off her top and she
does not take off her bottom was because
she has a penis nobody knows she's
transgender
Quinn says nobody knows you're
transgender and you have a penis what's
the difference
that is to say
people read him as male because he's
male and why do you call Bambi a
supposed transgender person Quinn asks
we can go into that but if she
surgically altered parts of her body
that's transsexual I know that's a
controversy in and of itself but I can
explain that
Quinn says are you saying that
transitioning either hormonally or
physically somehow disqualifies someone
from being authentically transgender
and he says you have to understand
gender identity everybody's confusing
you're internal with your external all
these external people are doing what is
being called transitioning there's no
transition that's called deviation I'm
tired of that word transitioning it's a
fake word that people like Bambi use the
whole point is this is how you are born
so and this is the guy
and
he's saying that people who are actually
living this with Downstream consequences
for themselves who are actually having
the surgery and the hormones
are a different kind of thing and he's
the real deal because he's just a dude
who likes to go naked into women's
spaces and be a nightmare I've said he's
confused and he doesn't belong in these
spaces yeah I don't think there's any
confusion here hold on
you and I have said
that in fact trans is a very rare but
long-standing thing and that what is
highly unusual is that we have now taken
technology and decided that if you are
trans in the sense that you have this
profound dysphoria or whatever the
defining characteristic is that you are
entitled to modify yourself in with
technological help right and the point
is you have a long-standing something
that appears to Exist Elsewhere and then
you have a modern medical something and
the question is what is the relationship
now I don't like this guy's argument if
people are actually trans and they have
this profound dysphoria and then they
make a decision to modify themselves I
don't see that anything about their
psychological state is lost so I don't
see why he would exclude them from the
category but his point is the fact of
whatever the psychological state is is
distinct from the physical modification
well I think and maybe and this gets to
the next piece that we're going to talk
about but
um
he thinks that gender identity is real
as do all the trans rights activists
confused gender identity isn't real and
like everyone it seems who reads now the
New York Times and Martian post and NPR
is told that they really have to accept
the gender identity is real or else
they're transphobes well I'm sorry no
like gender exists in non-human animals
and sex exist in almost every life on
the planet right gender as the software
to the hardware that is sex as in an
animal that can move around the behavior
the behavioral ramifications of the sex
that you are
this guy's position
I have seen nothing and this is the only
piece I've read about him
um but there is nothing anywhere in this
piece that indicates anything about him
actually feeling like a woman like I
don't there's no evidence that he
actually has the confusion in any way
right he just went to the DMV at the
point that it became legal to do so and
said I know
I know what I can do I can continue to
walk around and have sex with any
straight woman will have me as the band
that I am but then I also now get to
enter women's spaces so he gets it both
ways and isn't that a dream for him okay
so one one more one more little section
from this yeah okay
um so one more section Zach let's get
back to we Spa Quinn says what brought
you there that night
I re-injured my back in an unprovoked
attack in Malibu
and I went to Wii Spa because it's the
only place in town you can get hot and
cold treatment which is one of the best
therapies you can get for
anti-inflammation
were you living near Koreatown no I was
in the neighborhood my local pool in the
marina was closed for maintenance
did you go to Wii Spa often no I've only
been there twice I had to do physical
therapy every couple of days and I roam
a lot
everything in that interchange says
Predator to me unprovoked attack in
Malibu oh it's about the hot and cold
treatment but he didn't go to his pool
which wouldn't have had either of those
oh because it was closed for maintenance
oh we don't live near there I just roam
a lot like this guy is just like every
female Spidey Sense part of me yep it's
like oh no you you keep this guy out of
women's prisons out of women's faces out
of every Everything having to do with
single sex spaces for women you and I
all have zero disagreement about that of
course
my point is the most dangerous people
are the people who would set up a rule
where this is a question I'm not
defending them well but
in effect you are ending up in the same
place that they are where the point is
look you're female if you say you're
female unless we say you're not I'm not
in the same places then well in some
sense you're you're you're not in the
same they never should have set that up
and this guy who's who looks like a
predator is taking advantage of it and
you know I just just you know there are
arguments about bad tax laws that allow
rich people to not pay enough taxes yeah
and some honorable rich people say you
know what I am simultaneously going to
take advantage of the of the tax laws
that shouldn't exist so that I don't
have to pay as much taxes because I'd be
foolish not to but I'm also going to
work to change those tax laws so that we
can get a better world right right this
this is just a predator taking advantage
of a really bad situation which was
created by activists it was created by
activists but the point is those
activists de facto position is you're
female if you say you're female unless
we say you're not and and they say he's
not Okay so I don't like accepting the
second part of that formulation the
point is the only place to solve this
issue is at the no you're not female if
you say you're female now you may have
to set a standard given that there are
transsexuals we do have to figure out
what the standard is that decides
whether or not your driver's license
declares you female I mean how crazy is
it if you don't look female the idea
that your driver's license says you're
female is not about how you feel it's
about how to pursue you if you commit a
crime right it's a description of you so
that we know who you are if you're you
know car rolls over and we need to
identify you if you've committed a crime
and we need to find you it's totally
insane we just had we just got uh
submitted a passport renewal for one of
our sons this week uh and now you can
put X down you can choose m for male f
for female or X for either other or
doesn't want to have said declined to
say you shouldn't be able to say that on
your passport your passport you should
not be able to say that on your passport
right of course not of course not so
anyway my position is look there is no
excuse for this guy being in these
spaces but
the idea that there's a rule that says
you are what you say you are right but
but acknowledging that this guy's a
predator who's behaving extraordinarily
badly is not is not giving cover to the
people who helped create the rules
well but the problem is that
because this guy does not look female
right because he's not
yes but some people do look female who
are not
yeah okay and they're also not right but
the point is there is a part of this
that's like there's nothing female about
this guy right and the answer is
unfortunately these insane people have
created a rule in which that doesn't
matter
right and so it's as you know I'm not
arguing for this guy's discretion to go
into the women's spot right what I'm
arguing is that the insanity is that
we've created a rule and what these
people have done is they have created an
exception to the rule that they don't
even spell out
right who are you to question this
person's sex
uh I'm a biologist right doesn't count
doesn't matter biology says sex isn't
binary okay they're the only Arbiters
they create a rule and they're the only
averages I I agree that that's insane
but the fact that I come in this
particular case that I end up agreeing
with them doesn't make him anything less
of a predator well I mean look you don't
know for sure what what he is or isn't
um
like he's Quinn asks him several direct
questions like he's been in prison for
uh
he's a convicted sex offender because he
was masturbating while peering into the
window of an 85 year old Arcadia woman
the guy says
yeah but I was masturbating that's not
illegal that's not an answer and it was
illegal he like
oh okay so there's a question creep is
nowhere close to strong enough this
creep is nowhere close to Strong Enough
totally agree on the other hand you know
all of the creepy [ __ ] that exists in
porn now right the fact is there's like
we're talking about this guy no we're
talking about we've got an industry
which caters to creep okay absolutely
okay so the point is being a creep ain't
illegal he's right about that okay I
don't know what the situation was with
the window whether he was breaking the
law or not presumably he was because he
was convicted but my point is
Western Civilization has a problem with
this exact concept right it does not say
creepiness is unacceptable it says
actually true it's monetizable okay so
this is true in a world where creepiness
is on the menu and your gender is what
you say it is because a bunch of crazy
people have gained enough power to make
that the rule I don't want to place that
at this person's doorstep nor do I want
to assume that I know what he's getting
out of it yeah I assume he's getting
sexual gratification from being naked in
front of a bunch of women that he's not
really entitled to be naked in front of
but why is he there because a bunch of
insane [ __ ] change the rules so that
we can't enforce anything that makes any
sense so maybe
what your position is the part of your
position that I wasn't seeing before is
I Brett see most of what you Heather are
seeing in this article
but
I don't see evidence that this is the
worst of what is being produced by the
system that they're actually like this
looks pretty clear-cut but there
actually are some ambiguities but
there's a whole lot of place where there
appear to be ambiguities where there
actually aren't and we need to be
thinking system-wide about and as we are
but we need to be thinking system-wide
about how depraved We are Becoming right
we have to think about how depraved We
are Becoming and frankly at a game
theory level this isn't hard there's one
place to solve this problem and it has
to do with the rules and yes you may
need some discretion for edge cases but
the one place to solve this is to make
an unambiguous rule about who is and is
not allowed to join the sport to go to
this prison to join this women's space
okay that's the place to solve it
there's no other place that is even
remotely viable yeah and you know
actually it occurs to me and this is
something we've talked at before but I
it never quite
occurred to me before to think that
actually their language around what
happens when the doctor sees you for the
first time if you didn't have uh
ultrasound or amnio or something and so
your sex hadn't been observed before
birth
at the point that your sex is observed
at Birth and there's is assuring us that
it's assigned that moves reality into
um
into this space of discretion that that
takes reality from reality to
discretionary space and so once reality
is discretionary then everything is
discretionary like it's it is stolen
from us the part where like no actually
there's a there's a base truth here
dude's a dude and in in this case he's
not even trying and in other cases they
are trying and it doesn't matter still a
dude yep so I before we go on to a case
that does show what the worst of this
looks like yeah
um I want to make one other point and
it's going to be a little hard for many
people to grasp why it's related here
okay but
years ago I gave this tedx talk on the
personal responsibility Vortex and the
basic point is there are two kinds of
systems in the world there are systems
in which the cleanup is done by the
benevolent people
those systems evolve towards being
ruthless and there are systems in which
the ruthless pay the cost of cleaning up
the system and those systems evolve
towards benevolence you can adjust the
rate at which you evolve in these two
directions but you're one side of the
line or the other so the idea that the
place to enforce this is but are you
really trans right this is discretion
and we're going to doubt you in all of
that creates a hellscape right in which
this is all going to be done based on
selective enforcement and people's
judgment and who has the power the only
place to create a system
you won't get everything you want out of
the system you won't protect every
single person who's in need of
protection but the way to protect the
maximum number of people from the
various harms that actually threaten
them is by structuring rules that are
themselves sensible and then
adjudicating those cases in which you
cannot easily apply the rule using some
sort of discretion where we know what
the law was trying to do when we say
here's the best we can do in this case
right so
what I'm getting at is the hellscape in
which this is discretionary is the one
in which the good people pay right and
just as we don't want to create tax law
that's vague and have people you know
abide by it on their honor we want to
create tax law that's utterly
unambiguous and make it so that the
people who pay are the people who
actually violate the rules right this is
a case where you want good rules
and then you want them enforced utterly
without prejudice right and
um we're headed in the other direction
because
dangerous people and their simpleton
Partners have engineered a set of rules
that you know a child could gain
[Music]